each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay let's get started it's my pleasure
to introduce couch xn kai-shek is
getting his PhD at the urbana champaign
working with Professor galaga Koscheck
has done a lot of work in a lot of
different areas but think he's primarily
a program analysis guy stun static
analysis dynamic analysis testing bunch
of other stuff and he will tell you more
about it in his talk he's also recently
won a distinguished paper award at FS e
05 for his work on can collect testing
and so anyway I'll not take any of
caustics time and now go ahead thank you
so good morning everyone today I'm going
to talk about my research primarily
focusing on my work on scalable
automated methods for software
reliability so let me just give you an
outline of my talk i'll start by
reimagining the motivation behind my
research and after that i will be one
specific topic of my research which is
dynamic program analysis and i'll show
its applicability to testing testing
content and sequential programs and then
i will show you some case studies which
will show the application of my work to
real-world programs and after that i
will give you the big picture my
research in other areas and mention some
future research plans okay so good so
why you software reliability important
software is everywhere it's permitting
every aspects of her life and it is
getting more and more complex day by day
and software reliability is a grand
challenge nowadays in fact in 2002 nice
report claims that chakra failures
currently calls the US economy an
estimated sixty billion dollars per year
and if we can improve the software
testing infrastructure then you can say
one third of this cost it is not the
case that we are not trying to develop a
reliable software in fact in the
software industry fifty to eighty
percent of the total software
development cost goes into testing only
so the developers and industry is trying
hard to develop reliable software but
our methods
techniques are not good enough now
they're several approaches to address
this problem of software reliability
like say pipe systems and safe
programming languages static program
analysis dynamic program analysis with
inputs testing and run time monitoring
model checking and theorem proving and
other formal methods model based
software development and analysis but
each one has its limitation for example
in case of static analysis you get false
positives in case of testing it's mostly
ad-hoc where you manually translate the
specification into test inputs and you
do the testing in my research I focused
on this domain which involves dynamic
program analysis includes runtime
monitoring testing model checking and so
on and today in my talk I'll only focus
on testing will give you the technical
details of my work in con colic testing
and i will discuss my work in other
areas of dynamic program analysis
briefly up at the technical part okay so
next I'm going to describe a new method
of testing for sequential programs which
we call con colic testing so what is the
motivation behind testing what is our
goal in testing sequential programs we
want to generate a set of test inputs so
that whenever we execute the program on
these inputs we can catch bugs so for
now I'll only focus on generic bugs like
assertion violations uncaught exceptions
that eraser a block at server later I'll
also talk about specifics on related
birds now observe one thing if we can
generate a set of paste inputs that
would force a program to execute any
reachable statement in the program then
we can catch any generic error like
assertion violation uncaught exception
or something like that clearly you can
do this if we can execute all the
feasible execution paths of a program
now let me last it clarify this given a
sequential program we can see all the
feasible execution paths of the program
as this binary tree which is called
amputation free where each into
node represents the execution of a
conditional statement or an if then else
statement and each edge represents the
execution of a sequence of non
conditional statements now note one
thing given a sequential program there
can be several inputs that would force
the program along the same execution
path our goal would be to generate a set
of inputs so that each path in this tree
is executed exactly once obviously we
cannot even try to explore the whole
tree if it is infinite in size so in
such situations we restrict our
exploration to a finite depth or we can
use various new sticks like statistical
techniques or machine learning or
similar static analysis to prune the
search space so let me explain this
computation 3 through an example which
I'll use as a running example so
consider this function test me which is
the function we want to test and it has
two inputs x and y each of type integer
and they there you have an assignment z
is equal to double of y where the
function double is defined here and then
you have two conditions if z is equal to
equal to x then if x is greater than y
plus 10 then there is an error now all
the feasible execution paths of this
program for all possible values of X&Y
can be seen as this computation tree
which has exactly three execution paths
now our goal would be to explore this
tree now there are several existing
approaches to address this problem and
one such method is random testing in
random testing you generate random
values for this x and y and for this
inputs and then you execute the program
now random testing is widely successful
in catching many bugs but it has its
limitation it cannot guarantee good
coverage of the program for example if
we take this simple program test me
which takes as an input X and which does
this comparison then if we generate
random values for this X then the
probability of hitting this error is
extremely low it's in fact 1 by 2 30 32
and the problem becomes events also if
we have inputs which are complex data
structures
then we cannot even try to generate a
random input value that will crash the
program or that will explode the whole
computation tree so one way to address
this problem is to use symbolic testing
in symbolic testing instead of using
random values for the inputs use
symbolic values for the inputs and then
we execute the program symbolically and
whenever we reach some conditional
statement we try to check whether either
the branches can be taken using a
theorem prover now symbolic testing
gives us good coverage unfortunately it
cannot handle all the features of the
real world program for example let us
consider this method test me this takes
us an input X and which has this
conditional X modulo 10 times 4 is not
equal to 17 then there is Error one and
otherwise there're two so here error to
is only reachable error one is not
reachable now if we assume that our
theorem prover that is used for the
symbolic testing cannot risen about the
theory of arithmetic with the modulo
operator which is the case then at this
point a symbolic gesture will get start
it doesn't know whether either the
breath just can be reached or not so it
will either stop at this point or if it
is a car if it is a practical symbolic
testing tool then it will say both the
branch is invisible in that case it will
give false positive the problem becomes
0 if we have some function for which we
don't have the code even like some
library function then we cannot even
think of executing this function
symbolically and then also you cannot
decide whether either the branches can
be taken or not so again we will get
either false positive I'll get stuck now
where is this problem we propose to
combine random testing and symbolic
testing so that we can get the best of
both the words and we call this con
colic testing soakin colic testing the
word con colic uses the conc from
concrete & Olick from symbolic I picked
this name because it doesn't show up in
the google so that's
it's the controversial name so a
convention that I started this work I
was well as doing my internship at Bell
Labs two years ago and then I extended
after that I extended it with pointers
and data structures concurrency and
distributed message passing and other
things so I am going to describe this
method through a simple example through
the running example so we want to test
this method test me which takes input x
and y now if we generate random values
for this x and y the probability of
hitting this error is extremely low it's
1 by 50 / 33 what we propose is to
perform the concrete execution and
symbolic execution simultaneously so for
that we create two kinds of state one is
the symbolic state of the program which
is represented by this one where we
initialize the inputs it's symbolic
values or symbols and the same time we
also create a concrete state or the real
state of the program where utilize the
inputs with random values for example in
this case x is equal twenty-two and y
equal to seven and this line represents
the concrete execution and this line
represents the symbolic execution and
this represents the program counter now
we execute the program both concretely
and symbolically simultaneously so after
the execution of this statement Z
becomes 14 which is twice the Y but in
the symbolic state it is two times why
not so it is represented symbolically
and whenever we execute some conditional
statement we generate some condition
which we call the path condition and are
not one thing any assignment to the
inputs which satisfies this condition
would force the program along the same
path our goal would be to generate
another set of inputs so that we can
direct the program along a different
path so for that what we should do we
pick this constraint we negate it and we
solve it to generate new input values
which is X equal to 2 and y equal to 1
and now when you execute the program we
actually take a different path and again
we execute the program both concretely
and symbolically and
we go into the then statement then
branch of this conditional and at the
end of the execution we have this path
condition and we repeat the process we
pick one of the constraint which is this
one we negate it and we solve the
resultant constraint to get X equal to
30 and y equal to 15 now if you execute
the program on this newly generated
input then we actually hit the earth yes
consumer testing yes all such complete
evaluation I'll get back to that person
that is exactly the point and my next
few slides well not next few but future
some slides will show that yes yes
initially so what we do we have this
computation tree we generate some random
value and execute some path in the
program initially and after that we pick
some node which is using their depth
first search strategy for now we negate
it and solve it we generate a new input
and and you try to explore the tree now
it may happen that you may have explored
the whole tree and you may have some
made some approximation because of which
you have may have lose your completeness
then you start it again whenever you
lose completeness a generate another
fresh set of random values and start the
process again so these two things are
interleaved and also during solving the
constraints you can generate values new
inputs which are random so you might not
be a solid
random thing and then we may be able
let's take a simple program if X cube is
equal is greater than zero then some
error now if we generate say x is equal
to minus 10 we may not hit the error and
we stopped because you cannot solve
whether X is solution for X cube greater
than 0 then we generate another random
value say x is equal to 10 then we
actually hit the error so here the
random testing helps not the symbolic
part okay so we work on this path
exploration I and because of this we
call this is the C path model checking
not state model checking we are trying
to explore all the distinct paths in a
program and we continue this process so
you may wander so Smith let's discuss
and how is the symbol looks like a
symbolic testing how is it helping us so
realistic that let me change this
function a little bit let z is equal to
foo of why we're foo is defined here
which returns a complex expression V
times V modulo 50 now we perform this
con colic execution now at the end of
the execution you have this constraint
which is y times y modulo 50 is not
equal to X now you solve this and we
don't know our constraint solver cannot
handle the modulo operator so the
question is are stuck the same situation
can arise if we don't have the function
foo at all you do not have the body of
the function and then we have this
constant which is full of y is not equal
to X and we have to solve this again we
don't know what who is supposed to do so
re stuck the answer is since our
concrete state is a special case of the
symbolic state we can replace some of
the symbolic values by the concrete
values as a result we do approximation
we have sound but we lose completeness
we cannot catch all bugs and if we do so
we get the constraint which is 49 is
equal to equal to X and if we solve it
we get X equal to 49 and y equal to 7
and if you execute the program on this
newly generated input we actually hit
the error so
in this way we can go deep inside the
tree we can skip a some of the branches
we may not generate values for those
things but we can gain scalability in
this way so in a way where this con
colic testing can be seen as a middle
path between random testing and symbolic
testing where we get good coverage like
symbolic testing we can handle complex
programs like random basting we get high
coverage we don't have false positive
and we have somewhat deficient okay so
so I explained this con colic testing
the key idea behind con colic testing
behind using a very simple example so
that it is accessible to a broader
audience but things get complicated when
we have pointers and data structures
when you have concurrency and message
passing and those kind of things are not
going to the details how we handle
pointers and data structures but I will
give you an overview how we handle those
things I'll mention how we handle
concurrency though so in case of
pointers if our input is a pointer then
it can actually point to a memory graph
or a complex data structure and we
represent we propose the use of logical
input map to represent such data
structures symbolically so for example
this pointer this data structure is
represented by this memory map so not
going to the details you can discuss
this offline and to track the
constraints related to the point test we
use equality and dis equality
constraints which are of this form p is
not equal to null or p equal to null or
p is not equal to some other pointer or
it is equal to some other pointer and at
the time of solving the constraints we
do some approximation we decouple the
pointer constraints from arithmetic
constraints we do approximation and then
we generate equivalence class for each
pointer and then we solve this pointer
constraints by either adding a node and
pointing it to this p or deleting a node
that is pointed by p or the equivalence
class of p or make two equivalence class
equal by making them
to the same node or we add a node and
point both p or q to point to that node
so that they become unequal so this is a
very brief overview I'm not going to the
details and we also observed that in the
case of constraint solving we only
negate one constraint at a time so in
many cases our solution should be
similar to the previous solution and we
exploit this fat and we implemented a
incremental constraint solver and it
turns out that it's one hundred and two
thousand times faster than a night
constraint solver now you may ask like
we are just interested in statement
disability how this can be used to find
acceptance security births in programs
the answer is you can always translate
this kind of state properties into path
properties by automatically inserting
chicks in the program for example
suppose I is an input and if you want to
check whether there is a division by
zero then you can insert this thing if I
is not equal to 0 then is ok otherwise
there is an error similar thing happens
when you have an array access before the
array access you can check whether the
input value falls within the range of
the buffer length otherwise is an error
similarly for a integer overflow you can
put some chicks so basically using this
automatic automatic instrumentation you
can add these checks and then you can
pop on con colic testing yes quite a
list where you what input language is
what source language is do you buy you
we implemented this thing in C and Java
for testing see programs and java
programs but we assume that our core
language can be expressed in somewhere
in the ram model will you have slowed
and store and conditionals are branching
statements if it's in seed and how do
you know with the way to thee that's a
good question so this is this this is
good for java okay in case of see you
have to actually check whenever you have
allocated some memory location or array
then you have to keep it track of that
and you can add this test so you can be
done at runtime by adding some extra
variables and we don't do this actually
this is performed by some other tool we
can use it as it is yes reason why you
joined it as if statements and then some
error as opposed to just putting in the
surgeon you can do it assertions paula's
get compiled to because i just wanted to
make it explicit so that you can see
that there is a path or branching at
this point you can insert a site as well
that is a sign up here
this introduces more house where it's a
desert that's not I said actually
introduces a path if you if you expand
the macro it takes whether the assertion
condition holes are not other it will
throw an error otherwise it will go
inside the yes yes so this is a more
general thing I would say so that's why
I so instead of error you can just put a
third 0 or something like that it's not
a conditional you know yeah so so I
despite this con colic testing for
sequential programs but unfortunately
most of the programs in the real world
are concurrent programs where you have
several threats are processes executing
simultaneously and communicating either
through shared memory or through message
passing now you can model the execution
of such concurrent programs using the
scheduler which at every point of
execution picks one thread and execute
it now the question is how can we extend
this simple method of con colic testing
to taste concurrent programs yes
threading under multiprocessor configure
so in my talk today I will only talk
about multi-threaded programs with
shared memory we have done a separate
work for message passing programs where
you have separate processes and they
communicate through channels or
something else and it's not difficult to
combine the things you have to basically
track the point some non determinism and
resolve them in an effective way that's
the thing you have to do and
conceptually it's not difficult and this
can be extended so we can actually talk
about this if you are interested we can
talk of about it offline but let's see
how it works now testing concurrent
programs is not obviously difficult
because for a given input you can have
similar behaviors of the program
depending on how the scheduler results
the non determinism so if you have to
taste the content program effectively
you have to consider all possible
schedules for all possible inputs and
that is going to a very difficult task
for example if you consider this two
threaded program okay t1 which executes
X equal to equal to 100 then a equal to
1 is equal to and this thread t to
execute another conditional statement
and if we assume that x and y are input
to the program then the computation tree
for this simple to third program is this
huge tree well we have nodes not only
for the conditional statements but we
also have nodes for the scheduler choice
or the thread switch now in contrast if
you just consider a single thread this
one you just forget about this thread
then its computation is three is this
one which is only one node one internal
node so we got get an exponential
blow-up when i move to concurrent
programming there are several existing
approaches to address this problem of
testing content programs and one such
method is partial order a reduction so
there they observe that a number of
executions of mankind programs
equivalent each other with respect to
statement disability and this is called
partial order eruption and then for a
given program they assume that the input
space is small
are very small like if it is an integer
it can as in say zero one two and three
then for each input they try to taste
the program using partial order
reduction so these things do not scale
for programs which have complex inputs
and at the same time they have
concurrency now one way to address this
problem would be to combine symbolic
testing with partial order reduction and
that is done in the Java Pathfinder tool
from NASA Ames which is a model checker
for java programs but it has its
limitations it has the limitation of
symbolic execution as I described before
but the same time for the purpose of
partial or reduction they have to
determine the partial order or the
dependency among the various content
events and for that they have to do
pointer analysis and alias analysis so
that they can determine whether two
pointers are equal and whether they are
dependent or not now point analysis in
case of symbolic execution is always
conservative so it may give rise to a
number of redundant dependencies and as
a result 11 will explode a lot of
redundant executions in the program so
so there are serious credibility issues
when we use many combined symbolic
execution with partial order reduction
we observe that con colic testing
account colic execution is ideal for
testing concurrent programs why we can
use the symbolic execution we generate
inputs as before but we have this
concrete part and we can use it to
determine the dependency relation
exactly we don't have to do any alias
analysis or pointer analysis so so the
extended con colic testing with res
detection and rest flipping and I'll
give you the key steps behind this
method next so executions in concurrent
programs can be seen as partial orders
where the partial orders are over events
so in a Content execution events are
basically accesses to memory locations
it can be a read or a right or memory
acquire or release lock Ecuador
lock release and we say that two events
a and E prime are related with by this
partial or reduction if they are events
from the different threats and if the
excess the same memory location without
synchronization and at least one of them
is right or one of them is lock release
and other is lock acquire or if their
events on the same thread and one
happens before the other and we take the
transitive closure of this relation now
note one thing race conditions are
captured exactly by this partial order
relation so let me and we also made this
observation that if we can execute one
linear order or one execution for a
partial order then we can reach any
visible statement in the program you
don't have to explore all the linear
orders for a partial order so here is an
example of such a partial order consider
this to thread program p1 execute y
equal to 1 x equal to 1 and T to execute
X equal to three and if X is not equal
to 3 then there is an error now let us
consider this particular execution where
we first execute p1 and then we execute
t2 and this is the partial order
corresponding to this execution where
you see that there is a dependency
relation between this event and this
event because they both of them are
accessing the same memory location X
without any synchronization now we have
this execution what you should do to get
a different partial order
we try to flick this race between these
two events how we can do that we
continue the execution as before for the
first event get the same prefix now at
this point we want to flip the race so
for that what we do we postpone the
execution on the first thread and we
continue the other threats to execute
here we execute thread t2 and then we
continue with the remaining of the
execution as a result this race
condition gets split and you continue
the execution actually we heat the error
and as a result we get a new partial
order which is slightly different from
the previous partial order and now there
are technical things like you have to
track this race conditions you have to
make sure that you do not flip this race
conditions over and over again
repeatedly so there are certain
technical issues which we resolve by
using postponement set and delayed sets
and slip sets and then we prove that for
this algorithm this race taping abril
algorithm explores one linear order for
each partial order or one execution from
each equivalence class and for the
purpose of detecting race we use one of
our previous algorithms which we call
dynamic vector clock algorithm this
algorithm is is the flipping of golden
same as a dynamic national attention
yeah yeah so it has some similarities
they actually use they don't see it as
flipping of risk they they detect this
race conditions or these dependences and
then they construct this persistent sets
which is different from what we consider
we consider delayed six and there are
some and this this delayed says was
actually proposed in one of the previous
work from MIT and there they didn't
consider the dependency only the
dependency among the lock release and
lock a quest so use that and we found
that this is conceptually more easy to
follow and and in some cases actually
works better and so we have some case
studies moreover in in that work they
consider like any access to memory
location are dependent if they're if we
are done by different states we say that
two reads are not dependent and that's
why use this dynamic vector clock
algorithm and this is not there in the
literature algorithms are developed
where they just assume that any excess
pmma location is depending if their
access by different rates
behave differently from the passion our
direction
we have some examples I can
Lemonier institutional regístrate
against all forms that's why the memo
that always true or
which depends also such as well
on which conditions well if you combine
with Khan colic testing then you do all
these approximations then you cannot
guarantee that you have explored one
linear order for each partial order
because because of this approximation
you may lose some of the partial orders
you may not be able to generate input so
that's why yeah and then we can prove
some theorem actually I'll get get to
that later so in the dynamic Victor
clock algorithm we respect the fact that
two reads can be permitted they are not
dependent with each other and then he
proved that if two events are related by
this race relation then the vector clap
of one event is component wise less than
or equal to the character clock of the
other event and stop mentioning that we
took this lemma as our goal and we
derive the whole algorithm
mathematically now if we combine this
con colic testing with this recitation
already flipping we end up exploding the
small part of the tree and finally we
prove this theorem which says that which
gives the soundness and the completeness
of this combined algorithm it says that
our algorithm is sound because whenever
we find a bug we have an evidence or an
input and schedule that will lead to
that pub it's not complete in all case
that is we cannot guarantee that
whatever we can heat any visible
statement in the program but we can
guarantee the completeness in limited
cases that is whenever our program
terminates and when we do not make any
approximation or we can solve any
constraint that you have generated then
we guarantee that we have hit any
feasible statement in the program yes
that doesn't happen often but we're
always sold all the countries and the
algorithm terminates actually it solves
most of the cases if we have like simple
programs which are not numerical
algorithms or something in graphics then
the constraints here observe that they
are not complicated they are mostly
linear or simple and we can solve them
so you don't do approximation that
frequently when you have programs using
simple data structures or something like
that what is the result it means the
result we cannot guarantee but then we
have we can tell the user that we have
made some approximations and this part
we may not be able to explore so you can
go ahead and check manually flipping I
mean we modify the scheduler oh yes we
modified the schedule we implemented it
in for java and there we perform
instrumentation like before any memory
access we put one function call which
basically gives the control twist a sum
of two a central scheduler which we have
implemented and then it schedules the
threads now so far I discussed a new
method of testing for content programs
and sequential program so we can catch
genic bugs such as data raise deadlock
assertion violations and so on
unfortunately errors in programs are not
only generate but they can be due to
some specification or requirement so
there can be a formal specification of
the program for the correctness of the
program so I am NOT going to the
controversy whether we should have a
specification or not whether it is
correct or complete I will just assume
that we have some specification and then
from that point we want to test it now
our method for the method that I
described is not good when we want to
test the program against a formal
specification so let me lest it that to
an example if we have disputes read
program
x is equal to 3 and y equal to 2 they
are executed by different rates our
method that I described earlier it will
only explore this particular partial
order and it will stop because that's
only partial order in this program now
you're fine because you have reached all
the response statements in the program
unfortunately if we have a formal
specification in temporal logic say
always x is greater than y then this is
not sufficient because for this partial
order we can have another linear order
which actually Hylas this property at
this point x is equal to 0 and y equal
to 2 and it violates this all condition
which is always x is greater than Y so
our method is not complete when you have
a formal temporal specification so the
question is we have to explore the whole
tree like to explore all the physical
execution paths of the program for all
possible inputs and schedules the answer
is unfortunately is we have to do it if
we have formal specification but there
is good news we can we showed that we
can effectively explore all the linear
orders for a partial order without
reacts acuson and this method is called
predictive analysis this you develop yes
you consider temporal formula justice
which is on the side this way
alright
and appearances for faster
yes so that's a very good point you
noted like for this case you can just
have a third thread we can add every
access check whether X is greater than Y
but if you put such check how many times
you p is equal the program actually you
have to execute the program three times
and you have to execute you generate
schedule for each thing and you have to
consider but our claim is that we can do
it without VX equation we can just
instrument something get some
information and we can do it and this is
what we call proactive analysis i'll
describe it so let me give you the
intuitive idea behind this thing suppose
a cyclist is trying to cross the road
because the walk sign is on at the same
time a part is moving on the road
because the traffic signal is green due
to some Fault in the traffic system now
the cyclists misses the collision with
the car now from this scenario and he
says that something is wrong with the
perfect signal if you are doing testing
we say no there is nothing bad happened
the car didn't hit the cyclist but note
one thing the crossing of the road by
the cyclist and the movement of the car
on the road are causally independent
they are not dependent by any cousin
causal event so what we can try to do we
can reorder these two events and make
them happen in such a way so that the
car actually fits the cyclist so for my
psych successful scenario we can predict
another scenario where something bad
happens so this is the key idea behind
predictive analysis so what we do we
take the event place of execution of the
concurrent program annotated with vector
clock the dynamic vector cross that I
algorithm that I described before and
partial state update which is relevant
for the formula and we construct
something called computational artist
which you can find actually in the
literature of distributed systems now
one of the property of this computation
lattice is any path in this lattice is
an execution which is equivalent to the
original execution so what we have to do
to a check with the formal specification
against all the executions we have to n
you might all the paths in this lattice
and take them against the formal
specification and for this we will just
consider pastime linear temporal logic
formula and if we implement this knife
thing very it's and enumerate all the
execution paths in this lattice and then
check them against the final
specification then the time complicity
would be linear in the size of the
formula and exponential in the size of
the lattice because the number of paths
in this lattice is exponential we
proposed a new algorithm based on
dynamic programming which construct this
lattice on the fly and takes the cross
product with the formula and there we
showed that it can be done in time which
is linear in the size of the formula and
linear in the size of the lattice and
finally we prove this theorem which
shows that if we are given some temporal
logic formula and if we can find a
violation of the formula against doing
this running this algorithm then there
exists at least one linear order which
actually wireless the specification so
our original execution may not violate
the property but from this algorithm we
can find bugs in other closely related
executions of the program so as a result
we got a combination of three methods
yes w is the width of the lattice
to the left
wait what is it
this thing like the
maximum distance from one end to the
other day or actually it's it's equal to
the number of nodes in a particular
level of the lattice that's how we
defined with the pro lattice and L is
the length of any path in this lattice
yes so that's a good point actually it
may happen that the program has very
unsynchronized events and in that case
the size of that blue can be exponential
in the size of the trace but that
happens very rarely and in that case we
propose something which we call a a
causality cone sweeping of the lattice
where we show that not all the nodes in
the lattice relevant because you may not
want to permute two events which are
like happening one days apart you do not
want to and though if you want to do
that they will fall far in the lattice
and you don't want to explore them so we
have some mechanism to avoid that
explosion this the reason why you can
get
the size of the formula is because you
you only examine a finite set of states
yes because if you do one time and I was
yes he is
yes we are only interested in safety
properties we cannot verify a liveness
property or something like that what is
said it's static as well as I started do
not get anything checking for
performance against the telephone
yeah it's static in that sense and the
linear complexity only occurs in case we
have the past and linear temporal logic
formula in case of future time it
actually becomes exponential in the size
of the formula but the formulas are
always small so it doesn't pose a
problem okay so we have a combination of
these three methods which is con colic
testing recitation and rest flipping and
creative analysis which gives us an
automated and an effective approach for
testing content programs not only to
find generic problems in the program but
also to find from births related to the
formal specification now we implemented
these methods in two tools
excuse me one is called the cube which
is for testing C programs and other is
called J cube which is for testing Java
programs and both the tools are
available online for download we did
some case studies we tested several data
structure libraries in C and one such
library is the SD leap library which is
a popular c library for data structures
it has been widely used and it's used in
one of the commercial tool called extra
factory for reflecting C and C++
programs so we took this library and a
try to evaluate our tool how it works
but surprisingly we discovered two bugs
in this library and one is the
segmentation fault which occurs when a
doubly linked list non zero length w
linked list is concatenated with a
zero-length list and other is a bug in
the hash table which is an infinite loop
which occurs in this is member function
of the hash table and we reported this
bugs to the developers and they
acknowledged then they fixed it in the
next release so here is the statistics
for the for this case study you'll see
that in most of the cases the runtime of
testing is less than five minutes we
restricted our depth to 50 and he got
the coverage which is okay something is
wrong
it's on all the time the coverage we got
is almost around ninety six percent or
more in case of hash table since it uses
some complex hash function which is not
friendly to the symbolic execution we
got a coverage which is like 85 person
and in case of red black tree it had lot
of branches and everything so he got a
runtime which is pretty bad which is
like 45 minutes and also got an coverage
like 70 person this is low because they
introduced a lot of assertions just to
check whether the tightness of this hash
table and these assertions cannot be
violated anyway so he got very good low
coverage here the coverage is with
respect to the branch coverage we also
took the yes
yeah so we only consider 50 branches in
the in a given path 50 branches which
can be which is symbolic so it may also
we just ignore the branches which are
non symbolic so yeah then we don't get
we do not get to explore the whole
computation tree in reasonable amount of
time it blows up because whenever you go
down it the you get exponential blow-up
and it then from this numbers nadia for
the relation of timing
so i was just across went slowly
across you
that's a good question actually I then
make any study of that but my sins we do
many approximation you only maintain
like linear constraints and pointer
constraints which are equally candy see
quality a symbolic execution is very
fast and constraint solving just uses LP
salt and it is also quite first so
doesn't take that much of time but it's
always going to be several orders higher
than the concrete execution because for
everything every operation you have to
call a symbolic function which does the
manipulation yes so usually what happen
is that if there are two or three
unrelated branches and then you get down
you get an exponential be a scale which
that's so did it happen in do you think
it's happening in practice
actually the number of branches that
actually depend on the inputs are quite
low so we managed to explore the tree in
most of the cases and we found that in
most of the cases they are correlated
they are related by the inputs the
branch and the symbolic constraints and
it doesn't happen that they are not
correlated so that's my experience but
it may be the case where they are
totally unrelated and you end up
exploring more than what is required and
then I'm surprised that you are seeing a
blood flow of up to 50 it was not up to
50 it blew up when you went to like 100
or something we did some binary
increment so or not say like 60 or
something and there are several reasons
behind that I can take this offline so
another library that we test it is the
JDK 1.4 java.util library which
implement several a third slip
collections or data structures and the
claim is that if you execute several
methods of a data structure by several
threads then they can be serialized as
if they're executed by single thread and
we took this library because we thought
this is a good case study to evaluate
our tool but surprisingly discovered
previously undocumented concurrency
related buffs in this library such as
data is infinite loop uncaught exception
and deadlox and one such example is this
one this linked list if we execute this
clear and contains all by different
rates he actually can get into an
interleaving which that leads to an
infinite loop
that's such a what what is the what is
the function that you tested well that's
a good question so for this kind of
testing data structure libraries we
actually wrote a driver test driver
which in a loop calls the functions not
deterministically different functions of
a given library non-deterministic alee
and by different rates and that's how we
perform the testing and these tests i
was authorized by
so the linked list can be an input
something like that and here is the
detailed statistics I don't know it is
behaving lisa is this so here is the
statistics which shows that we actually
got a number of errors related data a
state law but at a point that these are
only due to a couple of problematic
design patterns used in the
implementation of this library and they
can be fixed easily he also compared our
tool with two other tools which state of
art model checking tools one is the vase
of tool for checking model checking see
programs and there we took the
implementation of an even shorter
protocol and ATM in protocol and it took
less than 15 seconds to find a known
attack in this in this protocols in
comparison raised up to eight hours to
find the same bar when they used a
combination of heuristic search and
manual guidance they found the bug or
the assertion violation in 55 minutes
yes the number of 3205 yes so why five I
mean they define a lot of parts that you
couldn't find my tooth threat sir
just creaky hydrates it's there is no
because two-thirds may not show up bugs
that's what we thought but most of the
cases I still like we found out he can
actually find the policy to face yes yes
so our this implementer of this Needham
sugar protocol actually implemented the
adversary model and put some assertions
which he violated indicates that there
is an attacking the program so we didn't
look into the code we just took it for
granted and we tested it yes yes
so the other case studies we also
compared with the case studies made by
the job path Explorer job Pathfinder
tool from NASA Ames and one on one of
the case studies is the DUS real-time
operating system and there we found this
subtle time purchasing error within less
than in less than a minute in comparison
job Pathfinder actually ran out of
memory when they tried to model check
the actual program so they have to
perform some obstruction and then they
took 11 means to find the same problem
since cute which is the testing tool for
C programs is incremented in see itself
we thought we should test the tool by
using the tool itself and so we took
several that data structure library is
used by this tool and tested using q and
as quite confident that there were no
problem in the program because I'm quite
good programmers so sir but
unfortunately I discovered some
segmentation falls and memory leaks in
the program and after that I have been
very programming very carefully and
always check you with Cuba for checking
in the program so these tools are made
publicly available in December or
January of this year and it can handle
whole of C and Java programs and the
binary available for download and
researchers and developers actually
download this tool and they're using in
their research or in development work
there is some commercial interest also
we fight to patterns on this technology
and a testing company is interested in
licensing the IP Illinois ventures is
also interested in starting a company
out of this but my personal interest is
to do some research impact on software
reliability so that ends the technical
part of my talk and now i will give you
a brief overview about the big picture
and my research in other areas so I
focused on this this domain which is
dynamic program analysis and testing so
I described today con colic testing and
red sleeping and predictive monitoring
but sometimes testing
cannot find all kinds of bugs in the
program because of this incompleteness
so there one can use runtime monitoring
one of the methods that I developed so
there are the ideas from the formal
specification you synthesize some kind
of monitors or state machine and then
you instrument those things inside the
program swings and then whenever you run
the program they can dynamically check
the formal specification against the
execution and report any problem in the
program now monitoring becomes
interesting when you have disputed
systems and there we show that it can be
done effectively by implementing some
decentralized techniques so this is also
interesting I cannot go into the details
so these things are directly applicable
to programs but I also work on modeling
and model checking problems in
particular I extended rewrite theories
with probabilities and called publicity
right theories it's very suitable for
specifying our programming network
protocol so it we replace the non
determinism by probabilities or sensor
networks and for those kind of
specification we also develop
statistical model checking where we
check a probabilistic property like
quality of service property etc against
the formal specification in a
collaborative walk also applied
completion of machine learning to verify
the safety properties of infinite state
systems and their the idea is the
reachable state space of interest rate
system is often regular so you can use
machine learning techniques to learn
this space space and check it against
the formal specification now quite
excited about this work and there are
some common themes in my research they
are all dynamic I saw a lot of
interaction between these various ideas
this scalable they are automated and I
do approximations from time to time to
get rid of the scalability to to make it
scalable and I brought in ideas from
other domains like machine learning
statistics randomized algorithms
probability theory operations research
and so on and also like to develop tools
based on these ideas and I develop
several tools for each of these methods
like dark cute and Jacob for con colic
testing Jay impacts for predictive
analysis
so on and we applied it to several case
studies I described some of them some
other interesting case studies we found
bug in the Mars rover software at NASA
Ames using the eagle 2 quadrant I'm
watering we also found safety and
security vulnerabilities in the open
source OSI protocol at bell labs but
also detected infusion in the DARPA logs
and so on so so soccer is everywhere now
i will give you some future research
directions it is pervading every aspects
of her life and software reliability is
a big challenge now it is and in my
research I tried to develop methods
which not only have rigorous theoretical
basis but also practical and applicable
to real world programs but I believe we
have only scratched the surface of this
problem and there is lot of things that
needs to be done in long term I would
like to extend this testing methods and
dynamic program and Isis methods to
other domains like hardware testing
testing embedded systems or even based
systems and so on I'd also like to
develop methods in which the soccer
becomes self healing they can monitor
itself at runtime and take necessary
actions so that nothing bad happens in
the system and my work in runtime
monitoring shows some direction in that
in that problem I'd also like to develop
some methods which can give some
measurable confidence in the software
reliability some quantitative notion
about how packed our program is and my
work in statistical program statistical
models you can show some directions in
that and in the near future I would like
to develop methods that can combine
static analysis with dynamic program
analysis so that we can prove the search
space a lot we can prove correctness of
some part of the programs while doing
dynamic program analysis and so on I'll
also like to extend this testing methods
to evolving software where you have
different versions of the software so we
have tested some part now don't want to
redo the
work for the new version so how we can
do such things using a dynamic program
analysis we also like to apply to sensor
network verifying such things and
develop methods where we can verify
concurrent programs and in the process i
would like to combine techniques from
other areas like machine learning
randomized algorithms operations
research and so on so there are civil
related work in this in this whole
domain of program analysis like scalable
testing testing concurrent programs
position based testing software model
checking static analysis type system and
say programming languages runtime
Watling and restitution this is not an
exhaustive list and in my research I
actually collaborate with several
researchers both from academia and
Industry and I'd like to thank them and
finally here is my conclusion thank you